we have the benefit of having dealt with
cords both in the context of samples
which obviously very silly too elusive
and also we dealt with cords of the
parabola right all we need my court is
well how would you define a cord to a
students never seen it before
okay you've got two points right that
one what a particular lockers right and
when what the that's be a little more
specific we want the interval that joins
those two okay so an interval has a
started end it's the two points you just
Mitchard array starts the weight goes
forever and a line goes forever in both
directions so the interval is what I'm
after
okay so therefore I need two points so
let's call them P at Q so give it two
points on the lockers I'll be this
now we already have some parametric
equations that make this quite easily
what's your state so for any given point
on the ellipse what we call that X away
I can't now in cartesian terms if I
didn't know anything about them I have
to call that so each other but a
parametric form I can call them a cos
theta and B sine you know very good but
for a caller I need a second point right
so I'll call that very mentally cute now
nicely there's something covered with on
the first point namely got a and B I'm
still the same do you agree with that
like that a squared B squared
I'm still the same ellipse right so
therefore this will be a and this would
be B but clearly I want a different
point on the ellipse right so I need a
different angle
right I just by convention if you're in
a theater mode rather than like Alpha
Beta Gamma etc what comes out to
theaters fine so this is a closed fine B
sine Phi yeah this is just there's just
not enough good symbols you know in the
world I mean where you been appealing to
a whole second alphabet and we still
it's big crowded in the now give it to
went to the ellipse pink use the code is
simply being a kid now if you want the
equation of a line if it gives you the
interval between these two points what
form are we going to use
frankerz yeah whoo wait on oh yeah we
could use either point gradient or 2.4
because using these two points I get
agreement
oh really those two are the same form in
case you didn't recognize like to point
is this right Y minus y1 on what
you're that recognize that okay now all
I need to do is multiply through by this
denominator and you should hopefully be
able to recognize let's put that y2
minus y1 on the top this denominator
here and then that guy over there that's
point greeting for my did the same for
which should surprise us because they're
going to give us the same line okay so
I've got to point to you so I'm just
going to go ahead and use the first four
so it's going to go like this why - for
reasons that will become clear even
brief moment I'm going to designate
what's a good position
this one is x1 y1 and this one has to do
yes
yes it is and this one that's gonna be
x2 one show that seems backwards but in
fact it's gonna give us exactly what
would be isolated so Y minus y1 that's
going to be B sign fine on let's see b
sine-theta
okay
so much of a muchness really now when
you look at this it looks like a mesh to
sometime I can simplify a tiny bit by
getting all the constants on one side
and all of the variables namely X or Y
or the other side so all that involved
is just a swap of these two okay
so going to check this guy over on this
denominator we get all the X's and Y's
over here and we put this denominator up
here to get all the constants a sorry
a B and our ankle was all on the
right-hand side as much as possible
anyway okay so it's a pretty minor shift
but it's gonna look like this and what
am i mad at you can also see on these
two down the numerator and denominator
for the right hand side I can factorize
a tiny little bit right so you can see I
can get a B out of this
and an a out of this
okay yeah we almost can't do any amount
anymore really almost if you have a look
at the left-hand side everything is kind
of reasonably nice and neat at least
I've got the right variables matched up
with the right constants that I'm
expecting because these are Y constants
and these are X constants okay over on
the right when you look at that that
seems like something simple enough and
like sort of what patented symmetrical
they ought to be some kind of identity
that should simplify this down and your
intuition should sort of say hmm I
wonder if I could write that in an
easier way and the answer is you can and
I'll show you what it is but I'm not
going to prove it and I will tell you in
a second
that's a wire why
okay so he's the identity to use
okay now to go from this to this right
from this which is you know it's not
that bad it's reasonably a captain up to
this which I think we can agree is
better like there's a single trig
function instead of four of them even
though the angle the argument you stick
in there is a bit of a mess but that's
okay
to get from that start to that star is a
moment somewhat dog-proof okay which is
why in an older version of the extension
to course when it was called when it's
properly called for you know without the
official name this result I will
actually cause of that inside of that
that was actually a quotable result for
extension to students they had to know
that just like they knew this sum and
difference values for sine and cosine
and tan and this is one of the cruise
it's not that difficult to go from this
like if I gave you no no excuse me this
with a minus on in the front and this I
could say prove this like it's an
identity no hard to do you just kind of
have to tease it apart it takes a little
bit
okay but you can't quit it and you can't
memorize it so there's kind of no point
having to go all the way through that
all you learn is a bit of trig which is
not actually gonna be that I'm clickable
which is why I was taken out of the
course
okay so I'm just going to for now leave
that just so you can recognize it okay
this is the equation of the cord on an
ellipse it's pretty much the simplest
form okay so this is a cord between any
P Q where P Q R arbitrary points on the
ellipse